Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. I'm speaking from London. It is late afternoon and the people of London are preparing for the night. Everyone is anxious to get home before darkness falls, before our nightly visitors arrive. The dusk is deepening. Listening crews are posted all the way from the coast to London to pick up the drone of the German planes. Soon the nightly battle of London will be on.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。我正在伦敦为您讲述。现在是傍晚时分，伦敦市民正在为夜晚做准备。每个人都急于在天黑之前、在我们每晚的“访客”到来之前赶回家。暮色渐浓。监听小组从海岸一直部署到伦敦，以捕捉德国飞机的轰鸣声。很快，伦敦的夜间战役就要开始了。
This has been a quiet day for us, but it won't be a quiet night. The searchlights are in position, the guns are ready, the people's army of volunteers is ready. They are the ones who are really fighting this war, the firemen, the air raid wardens, the ambulance drivers, and there's the wail of the banshee. The nightly siege of London has begun. The city is dressed for battle. The sun set over wartime London, blanketing the entire city in darkness. The streetlights on the mostly bare roads were dimmed or turned off. Slotted covers were fitted on the traffic lights and emergency vehicles to direct
这对我们来说是平静的一天，但夜晚不会平静。探照灯已就位，高炮已准备就绪，志愿民兵也已准备就绪。他们才是真正参与这场战争的人：消防员、空袭监视员、救护车司机，还有那凄厉的警报声。伦敦的夜间围城战开始了。这座城市已进入战斗状态。太阳在战时的伦敦落下，将整座城市笼罩在黑暗之中。大部分空旷道路上的路灯被调暗或熄灭。交通灯和紧急车辆上安装了开槽遮光罩，以将它们明亮的光线投射到地面。
their bright glow to the ground. Pedestrians navigated the shadowy streets with great difficulty. They were permitted to carry a small six-inch flashlight, but it had to be casted downwards and could only be turned on sparingly. This was the life of a Londoner since September 1939. The war had become the backdrop of everyday life. Walls were plastered with propaganda posters warning of Nazi espionage. Sandbags were piled high around lamp posts and in doorways. Barbed wire encircled government buildings which were protected by anti-aircraft weaponry. Pontoon bridges spanned the River Thames, its embankment peppered with concrete guard posts.
行人极其艰难地在阴暗的街道上穿行。他们被允许携带一支六英寸长的小手电筒，但必须向下照射，且只能偶尔开启。自1939年9月以来，这就是伦敦人的生活。战争已成为日常生活的背景。墙上贴满了警告纳粹间谍活动的宣传海报。电线杆周围和门口堆满了沙袋。铁丝网环绕着由高射炮保护的政府大楼。浮桥横跨泰晤士河，河堤上布满了混凝土岗哨。
Brick bomb shelters had been constructed throughout the city for civilians to swiftly hide in should the enemy bridge the perimeter. Most people chose to spend evenings at home, hidden behind windows covered with cardboard, thick curtains or black painted glass. Strict penalties were doled out to anyone who led even the slightest sliver of light escape. To hinder enemy aircraft from bombing attacks, the city had enforced the nightly blackouts, the least popular of all anti-bombardment implementations. It left the city's nightlife in quiet stasis, disrupting many lives and lowering morale. Looting theft, burglaries, robberies and gang-related crime increased under the cover of darkness,
全市各处都修建了砖砌防空洞，以便敌军突破防线时平民能迅速躲避。大多数人选择晚上待在家里，躲在用纸板、厚窗帘或涂黑玻璃遮挡的窗户后面。任何让哪怕一丝光线泄露的人都会受到严厉惩罚。为了阻碍敌机轰炸，城市实施了每晚的灯火管制，这是所有防轰炸措施中最不受欢迎的一项。它使城市的夜生活陷入了沉寂，扰乱了许多人的生活并降低了士气。在黑暗的掩护下，抢劫、盗窃、入室行窃和帮派犯罪有所增加，
as did rape and murder. On the night of Sunday, February 8, 1942, 41-year-old Evelyn Hamilton arrived at a boarding house in London's West End. She would only be staying for one night as she made her way further north to the port town of Grimsby. After unpacking and settling into her room, Evelyn asked the boarding house owner where she could get a late meal. She was directed to a restaurant approximately half a mile away on Oxford Street. It was nearing midnight when Evelyn rugged up and made her way through the cold, dark streets to the restaurant. One of the few places that maintained some element of the boisterous pre-war festivities
强奸和谋杀案也是如此。1942年2月8日星期日晚上，41岁的伊芙琳·汉密尔顿抵达伦敦西区的一家寄宿公寓。她只住一晚，随后将继续向北前往格里姆斯比港。整理好房间后，伊芙琳问房东哪里可以吃顿宵夜。她被指引到大约半英里外牛津街上的一家餐馆。临近午夜时，伊芙琳裹紧衣服，穿过寒冷黑暗的街道前往餐馆。少数几个仍保留着战前喧闹节日气氛的地方之一，
was Lion's Corner House. The large ornate eatery was a popular haunt for military men and volunteers tasked with safeguarding London at night. While it appeared dark and quiet from the outside, inside, the restaurant was a buzz with live music and patrons drinking to forget about the everyday stress of war. Evelyn was led to a table and ordered a celebratory glass of wine. Not only was it her birthday, she was about to start a new job as a pharmacy manager and was looking forward to new beginnings. By the time Evelyn finished her meal, it was early Monday morning. The sun had yet to rise. The transition from the bright restaurant interior to the unlit, foggy streets was disorientating enough, but Evelyn had to walk extra cautiously in her
是狮子角屋（Lion's Corner House）。这家装饰华丽的大型餐馆是军人和负责夜间保卫伦敦的志愿者常去的地方。虽然从外面看它显得昏暗安静，但餐馆内部却人声鼎沸，现场音乐响起，客人们饮酒作乐，试图忘记战争带来的日常压力。伊芙琳被带到一张桌子旁，点了一杯庆祝用的葡萄酒。这不仅是她的生日，她还即将开始一份药房经理的新工作，并对新的开始充满期待。当伊芙琳吃完饭时，已经是周一凌晨了。太阳还没升起。从明亮的餐馆内部过渡到漆黑多雾的街道已经够让人迷失方向了，但伊芙琳必须格外小心地走在她的
high heels. She made her way along Montague Place, passing a cluster of unoccupied, above-ground bomb shelters. As she walked by the central shelter, she was suddenly grabbed from behind and attract inside. Two men were walking along Montague Place when a weak beam of light caught their attention. It was emanating from a small torch that lay in the doorway of a nearby bomb shelter. The men went to investigate. Just inside the door lay the lifeless body of Evelyn Hamilton, her torn blouse exposing one of her breasts. Her skirt had also been lifted up with her underwear pulled below her knees. The men rushed out to alert a police officer and the cramped
高跟鞋上。她沿着蒙塔古广场走去，经过一群无人使用的地上防空洞。当她走过中央防空洞时，突然被人从后面抓住并拖了进去。两名男子正沿着蒙塔古广场走，这时一道微弱的光束引起了他们的注意。光线来自附近一个防空洞门口的一支小手电筒。两人前去查看。门内躺着伊芙琳·汉密尔顿冰冷的尸体，她撕裂的衬衫露出了一侧乳房。她的裙子也被掀起，内衣被拉到了膝盖以下。两人冲出去报警，狭窄的
shoulder was soon teeming with detectives. Scuff marks on Evelyn's shoes and broken pieces of mortar indicated she had fought to free herself during the skirmish. But she had no defensive wounds, meaning her killer struck fast and unexpectedly before she could gather her bearings and fight back. Bruising and fingernail abrasions along her neck showed that she had been manually strangled, which prevented her from screaming for help and resulted in her death. The absence of foreign fingerprints meant her killer had worn gloves. Evelyn's wristwatch was frozen in the one o'clock position, likely broken during the assault. This allowed detectives to narrow down the exact time she was set upon.
防空洞很快挤满了侦探。伊芙琳鞋上的擦痕和破碎的灰泥表明她在冲突中曾挣扎求救。但她身上没有防御性伤口，这意味着凶手下手极快且出其不意，让她还没来得及反应就遭到了袭击。颈部的淤青和指甲抓痕显示她是被徒手勒死的，这使她无法呼救并最终导致死亡。没有发现外人的指纹，意味着凶手戴着手套。伊芙琳的手表停在一点钟位置，很可能是在袭击中损坏的。这让侦探们缩小了她遇袭的具体时间。
A light layer of snow had fallen across the city that morning, but there was no chance of retrieving the perpetrator's footprints from outside the shelter. The movements of onlookers, detectives and other crime scene examiners had turned the snow into slush. The blackout had worked in the killer's favor by providing them with a cover of darkness and isolation. Because of this, no locals had seen or heard anything suspicious. Yet, the scene showed the killer was rushed and likely didn't finish what he had intended. While there was no physical evidence that Evelyn had been sexually assaulted, the state of her clothing indicated her assailant had intended to do so, but fled mid attack. Perhaps he feared he would be caught in the act.
那天早上城市里落了一层薄雪，但防空洞外已不可能提取到肇事者的脚印。围观者、侦探和其他犯罪现场调查人员的走动已将雪踩成了泥浆。灯火管制为凶手提供了黑暗和孤立的掩护，从而对他有利。正因如此，当地人没有看到或听到任何可疑情况。然而，现场显示凶手行事匆忙，很可能没有完成他预想的暴行。虽然没有物证表明伊芙琳遭到了性侵，但她衣衫不整的状态表明袭击者曾有此意，但在袭击中途逃离了。也许他担心会被当场抓获。
Evelyn's handbag was found discarded on the pavement not far from the crime scene. It still contained Evelyn's identity card and a ration book, but her wallet was empty of cash. Evelyn's sister told detectives that Evelyn was known to carry large amounts of money as she didn't trust banks. She believed Evelyn had 80 pounds stolen from her bag, the equivalent of 4,000 pounds today. It seemed highly unlikely that Evelyn knew her killer, given she was only briefly passing through London. She had never been in a relationship and there wasn't anyone within her social circle that could be immediately highlighted as a suspect. Men who Evelyn had encountered during her short stay in London were questioned, including the owner of the
伊芙琳的手提包被发现丢弃在离犯罪现场不远的人行道上。包里仍有伊芙琳的身份证和配给手册，但钱包里的现金不见了。伊芙琳的姐姐告诉侦探，伊芙琳习惯随身携带大量现金，因为她不信任银行。她认为伊芙琳包里被偷了80英镑，相当于今天的4000英镑。考虑到伊芙琳只是短暂路过伦敦，她认识凶手的可能性极低。她从未谈过恋爱，社交圈里也没有人能被立即列为嫌疑人。伊芙琳在伦敦短暂逗留期间遇到的男性都受到了盘问，包括
West End boarding house and other patrons at the restaurant she visited. One by one, they were ruled out, leaving homicide detectives with no feasible leads. Later that Monday night, 35-year-old Evelyn Oatley sipped a scotch in the King's Arm pub, just under two miles from where Evelyn Hamilton had been killed less than 24 hours prior. Evelyn Oatley had called London home for the past six years, making the big move from a poultry farm in Blackpool in the hopes of becoming a stage actress. The West End was renowned for its theatres, meaning it was the perfect place for Evelyn to settle down and begin her new career. The outbreak of the war changed everything. With Evelyn's theatre dream halted, she did
西区寄宿公寓的老板以及她光顾过的餐馆的其他顾客。他们被一一排除，导致凶杀案侦探没有任何可行的线索。那天周一晚上晚些时候，35岁的伊芙琳·奥特利在国王之臂酒吧喝着苏格兰威士忌，距离伊芙琳·汉密尔顿遇害不到24小时，地点相距不到两英里。伊芙琳·奥特利过去六年来一直以伦敦为家，她从布莱克浦的一个养鸡场搬到这里，希望能成为一名舞台演员。西区以剧院闻名，是伊芙琳定居并开始新职业的理想之地。战争的爆发改变了一切。随着伊芙琳的演员梦破灭，她
whatever she could to get by. It was a hard and lonely time, as the neon theatre lights that drew her to the West End were permanently shut off. When the King's Arms pub closed, Evelyn stepped outside into the crisper darkness and made her way to her bedside apartment on Wardour Street. She shared the building with two other tenants, an elderly man who lived on the floor above, and a woman named Ivy Poole who lived across the hall. Evelyn arrived home just before midnight. As she opened the front door and stepped into the hallway, she was suddenly bathed in light. Ivy stood on the landing above, having quickly flicked on a light to help Evelyn find her way up the stairwell. Evelyn expressed her thanks and made her way up. She wasn't alone.
竭尽所能维持生计。那是一段艰难而孤独的时光，因为将她吸引到西区的霓虹灯剧院招牌被永久关闭了。当国王之臂酒吧关门时，伊芙琳走到外面清冷的黑暗中，前往她位于华多街的公寓。她与另外两名租户合住这栋楼，一位住在楼上的老人，以及住在走廊对面的艾薇·普尔。伊芙琳在午夜前回到家。当她打开前门走进走廊时，突然被灯光照亮。艾薇站在上面的楼梯平台上，迅速打开灯帮助伊芙琳看清楼梯。伊芙琳表示感谢并走了上去。她不是一个人。
She was joined by a man in his mid-twenties and the pair disappeared into her apartment together. Ivy was aware that Evelyn occasionally engaged in sex work to make ends meet, but this was the first time she had seen her with a client so young. Ivy returned to her own apartment and could hear Evelyn's wireless radio playing as she chatted quietly with her male companion. At around 12.30, just as Ivy was beginning to doze off, she was jolted awake by blaring jazz music. The wireless in Evelyn's apartment had been turned up as loudly as it would go. This was unlike Evelyn's. She could hear Evelyn's being turned up as loudly as it would go. This was unlike Evelyn, who was considerate of her
她身边跟着一名二十多岁的男子，两人一起消失在她的公寓里。艾薇知道伊芙琳偶尔会从事性工作来维持生计，但这是她第一次见到她带这么年轻的客户。艾薇回到自己的公寓，能听到伊芙琳的无线电收音机播放着音乐，她正与男伴低声交谈。大约12点30分，就在艾薇开始打瞌睡时，她被震耳欲聋的爵士乐惊醒了。伊芙琳公寓里的收音机被开到了最大音量。这不像伊芙琳的作风，她很体贴
neighbors and never played music at such a volume. Ivy considered knocking on Evelyn's door to ask her to turn it down, but she didn't want to interrupt. Instead, she rolled over and tried her hardest to get to sleep. The music continued on for some time before it suddenly stopped and everything fell silent. The next morning of Tuesday, February 10, Ivy was reading the paper when there was a knock at her door. She was greeted by two workmen who were collecting money from the personal electricity meters installed in each apartment. At the time, light and heat were supplied to homes for an hourly fee via coin-operated machines. The two men asked if there was anyone else living in the building. Ivy told them about Evelyn Oatley, whom she assumed was sleeping in
邻居，从不把音乐开得那么大。艾薇考虑去敲伊芙琳的门让她调小音量，但她不想打扰。相反，她翻了个身，努力让自己入睡。音乐持续了一段时间，然后突然停止，一切陷入了寂静。第二天，2月10日星期二早上，艾薇正在看报纸时，有人敲她的门。两名工人来收取每间公寓安装的个人电表费用。当时，家庭的照明和供暖是通过投币机按小时收费的。两人问楼里还有没有其他人住。艾薇告诉他们伊芙琳·奥特利，她以为她因为昨晚熬夜而在睡懒觉。
after her late night. Ivy accompanied the workmen across the hall and knocked on Evelyn's door to her surprise that swung open on its hinges. Evelyn's apartment was cold, dark and quiet, with the electricity meter having run out. The blackout curtains positioned over the windows made it difficult to see anything inside, so one of the workmen shone a torch into the room. It illuminated Evelyn's body lying diagonally across her bed. Her head extended over the side, exposing a deep gash across her neck that pulled blood on the floor below. Ivy, still clad in her pajamas, rushed down the stairwell with the workmen in tow. They burst out onto the street where they spotted a policeman and called for his attention.
艾薇陪着工人们穿过走廊，敲了敲伊芙琳的门，令她惊讶的是门应声而开。伊芙琳的公寓里又冷又暗，一片寂静，电表里的钱已经用完了。窗户上的遮光窗帘让人很难看清里面的情况，于是其中一名工人用手电筒照向房间。光线照亮了伊芙琳的尸体，她斜躺在床上。她的头垂在床边，脖子上有一道深深的伤口，鲜血流到了地板上。艾薇穿着睡衣，带着工人们冲下楼梯。他们冲到街上，发现了一名警察并大声呼救。
We just found the dead woman, one of the workmen, cried out breathlessly. It was estimated that Evelyn Oatley was killed three to four hours prior. A blood-stained razor blade and a pair of hair curling tongs also caked in blood were resting on the blanket beside Evelyn's head. Positioned between her legs was a metal can opener with a sharp tip that was used to pierce tin cans. In this case, it had been used to carry out a violent sexual assault and mutilation. A small flashlight had also been inserted inside Evelyn where it still remained. Although Evelyn's throat had been cut, bruising and abrasions around the gaping wound and the hemorrhaging of her eyes revealed that she had first been
“我们刚发现了一名死去的女人，”其中一名工人气喘吁吁地喊道。据估计，伊芙琳·奥特利是在三到四个小时前遇害的。一把沾满血迹的剃须刀片和一把同样沾满血迹的卷发钳放在伊芙琳头边的毯子上。她双腿之间放着一个带有尖头的金属开罐器，通常用于刺穿罐头。在这种情况下，它被用来进行暴力的性侵犯和肢解。一支小手电筒也被插入了伊芙琳体内，至今仍留在里面。虽然伊芙琳的喉咙被割断，但伤口周围的淤青和擦伤以及眼睛的出血表明她先是
manually strangled. Once unconscious, Evelyn's throat was fatally slit with the razor blade. The majority of the sexual violence occurred when she was on the brink of death with the flashlight having been inserted into her body post-mortem. Evelyn's handbag and wallet were still in her apartment, but their contents were scattered and both were empty of cash. Only Ivy Poole could provide a description of the young man who had come home with her murdered neighbour. He hadn't said a word as he followed Evelyn into her apartment, but Ivy recalled his short wavy hair that was combed to one side. His pointed jaw was clean shaven,
被徒手勒死。失去知觉后，伊芙琳的喉咙被剃须刀片残忍割开。大部分性暴力发生在她濒死之际，手电筒是在她死后插入体内的。伊芙琳的手提包和钱包还在公寓里，但里面的东西散落一地，现金全无。只有艾薇·普尔能提供与她那位被谋杀的邻居一起回家的年轻男子的描述。他跟着伊芙琳走进公寓时一言不发，但艾薇记得他留着梳向一侧的短波浪发。他尖尖的下巴刮得很干净，
except for a mustache that framed the top of his thin lips. Standing about 5 feet 8 inches tall, he had been wearing a light blue overcoat buttoned up to the collar. Two women had now been violently murdered in Central London within a 24-hour period. Evelyn Hamilton's case was rare, involving an opportunistic killer snatching a random woman off London's darkened streets. In contrast, the murder of a sex worker wasn't nearly as uncommon. Evelyn Oatley's murder was also far more bloody and violent, carried out by a sadistic killer driven by sexual degradation. While the differences between the two slayings implied two distinct perpetrators,
除了嘴唇上方留着一撇胡子。他身高约5英尺8英寸，穿着一件扣到领口的浅蓝色大衣。在24小时内，两名女性在伦敦市中心遭到暴力谋杀。伊芙琳·汉密尔顿的案件很罕见，涉及一名机会主义杀手从伦敦黑暗的街道上随机抓走一名女性。相比之下，性工作者的谋杀案并不罕见。伊芙琳·奥特利的谋杀案也更加血腥暴力，是由一名受性变态驱动的虐待狂杀手实施的。虽然两起谋杀案之间的差异暗示了两个不同的肇事者，
police weren't so sure. After his seemingly unfinished public attack on Evelyn Hamilton, the killer might have learnt from his mistakes and struck behind closed doors, where there'd be less risk or distraction. Then there was the bruising on each of the victim's necks. It showed that they had both been strangled by a left-handed individual. Following the murder of Evelyn Oatley, London's sex workers were on heightened alert. The West End area in which the killer struck was referred to in the papers as the Mile of Terror. While some women were extra cautious about who they accepted as clientele, others couldn't afford to be picky. Some refused to be inhibited by fear.
但警方并不确定。在对伊芙琳·汉密尔顿进行看似未遂的公开袭击后，凶手可能吸取了教训，转而在门后作案，这样风险或干扰更小。此外，每位受害者颈部的淤青显示她们都是被左撇子勒死的。伊芙琳·奥特利遇害后，伦敦的性工作者处于高度戒备状态。凶手作案的西区在报纸上被称为“恐怖之英里”。虽然一些女性对接受客户格外谨慎，但另一些人却负担不起挑剔的代价。有些人拒绝被恐惧所束缚。
Although frowned upon by society, the act of paying for sex wasn't illegal, and sex workers were busier than ever. Wartime bred a sense of recklessness, as no one knew what the future held, driving people to indulge. Female police officers posed undercover as sex workers within the Mile of Terror, hoping to flush the killer out, but he didn't take the bait. Two nights after the Hamilton and Oatley murders, 28-year-old sex worker Patricia Borg walked the drizzly streets of London's Paddington District on the lookout for potential clients. It was nearing 10pm and business was quiet.
尽管社会不赞成，但买春行为并不违法，性工作者比以往任何时候都忙碌。战时滋生了一种鲁莽感，因为没人知道未来会怎样，这驱使人们放纵自己。女警官伪装成性工作者在“恐怖之英里”巡逻，希望能引出凶手，但他没有上钩。在汉密尔顿和奥特利谋杀案发生两晚后，28岁的性工作者帕特里夏·博格走在伦敦帕丁顿区细雨蒙蒙的街道上，寻找潜在客户。时间接近晚上10点，生意很冷清。
Wanting a break from the cold, Patricia stopped by an empty store front and lit a cigarette. Just as she was considering calling at night, a man approached and asked Patricia, will you take me home? I have two pounds. Given the city-wide blackout, Patricia struggled to see the man through the dark, but he spoke with a refined English accent that indicated he was highly educated. Two pounds was a substantial amount for the time, but despite being desperate for the money, Patricia declined. Something about the man's mannerisms gave her the creeps and the brazen way he propositioned Patricia made her wary. The man took a deep inhale of a cigarette and
为了躲避寒冷，帕特里夏停在一个空店面旁点了一支烟。就在她考虑收工时，一名男子走过来问帕特里夏：“你能带我回家吗？我有两英镑。”由于全市灯火管制，帕特里夏很难在黑暗中看清那个人，但他说话带着一种受过高等教育的优雅英式口音。两英镑在当时是一笔不小的数目，但尽管急需钱，帕特里夏还是拒绝了。这个男人的举止让她感到毛骨悚然，他向帕特里夏搭讪的厚颜无耻让她心生警惕。那名男子深深吸了一口烟，
backed away. He asked if Patricia knew of any woman who would have him for two pounds. She said no. The man then walked down the road and disappeared into the shadows. Everyone should carry his gas mask just as the civil defence services do. They're under strict orders and always carry them. How many of you carry your gas masks? Yet civilians are just as much in danger of a gas attack as the services and they should take the same precautions. You should have your gas mask with you always. If you're out in the street when the warning rattle goes, put on your gas mask and get undercover. Wherever you go, have your gas mask with you always.
退后了几步。他问帕特里夏是否认识任何愿意以两英镑价格接待他的女人。她说不认识。那名男子随后沿着路走去，消失在阴影中。“每个人都应该像民防部门那样随身携带防毒面具。他们有严格的命令，总是随身携带。你们中有多少人随身携带防毒面具？然而，平民和勤务人员一样面临毒气袭击的危险，他们应该采取同样的预防措施。你应该始终随身携带防毒面具。如果你在街上听到警报声，戴上防毒面具并寻找掩体。无论你去哪里，都要始终随身携带防毒面具。”
Later in the evening after Patricia Borg turned down her prospective client, 25-year-old Catherine Mulcahy was standing on the corner of Regent Street in the West End. A young man approached, his face barely visible in the faint glow of the cigarette he inhaled. With each smoky breath he stepped closer. Hying Catherine from head to toe, he asked, will you go with me? Catherine was apprehensive. Although the man smiled broadly and appeared friendly, his eyes were emotionless, like empty pits. Nevertheless, she accepted his offer and the pair climbed into a taxi bound for Catherine's
那天晚上晚些时候，在帕特里夏·博格拒绝了她的潜在客户后，25岁的凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希站在西区摄政街的拐角处。一名年轻男子走近，在吸烟时微弱的火光下，他的脸几乎看不清。随着每一次吞云吐雾，他走得更近了。他从头到脚打量着凯瑟琳，问道：“你愿意跟我走吗？”凯瑟琳感到不安。虽然那名男子笑得很灿烂，看起来很友好，但他的眼睛毫无感情，就像空洞的深渊。尽管如此，她还是接受了他的提议，两人坐上一辆出租车前往凯瑟琳位于
apartment near Hyde Park. By the time they arrived, Catherine was having second thoughts, but she had already taken the man's money and feared his reaction should she deny her services now. Neither Catherine nor the man had changed for the electricity meter, so Catherine burned a piece of paper and a saucepan to provide them with a few minutes of light. They removed their clothes and climbed into bed. For a brief moment, everything seemed to be going as planned. Then the man dug his knees hard into Catherine's stomach, winding her. He moved so quickly that Catherine had a little time to react.
海德公园附近的公寓。当他们到达时，凯瑟琳开始后悔了，但她已经收了男人的钱，担心如果现在拒绝服务会引起他的反应。凯瑟琳和那名男子都没有零钱投进电表，所以凯瑟琳烧了一张纸放在平底锅里，为他们提供几分钟的光亮。他们脱掉衣服上床。片刻间，一切似乎都按计划进行。然后，那名男子用膝盖猛击凯瑟琳的腹部，让她喘不过气来。他动作太快，凯瑟琳几乎没有反应时间。
Before she knew it, the man had wrapped his hands around her throat. There was no doubt in Catherine's mind that she was about to be killed. She fought back as best she could, thrashing, clawing and grabbing at her attacker. It was no use, he wouldn't let up. Realizing she was still wearing her boots, Catherine sourced what little energy she had left and kicked the man hard in the stomach. He rolled off the bed, cradling his gut, giving Catherine the opportunity to run out the front door. Kitty McQuillan lived across the hall from Catherine Mulcahy.
还没等她反应过来，那名男子就用双手掐住了她的喉咙。凯瑟琳毫不怀疑自己即将被杀。她尽其所能反抗，挣扎、抓挠并抓住袭击者。没用，他不肯松手。意识到自己还穿着靴子，凯瑟琳汇集了仅存的一点力气，猛地踢向男子的腹部。他从床上滚了下来，捂着肚子，给了凯瑟琳逃出前门的机会。基蒂·麦奎兰住在凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希的走廊对面。
It was 11pm when she heard the commotion outside her door and was startled by Catherine's voice screaming, murder, police. Kitty opened her front door just as Catherine rushed inside, naked except for a pair of boots. Kitty caught sight of the silhouette of a naked man through the doorway into Catherine's dark apartment before slamming her own door shut and arming herself with a heavy vase. The man called out in an unusually calm voice. Give me a light. Miss, give me a match.
晚上11点，她听到门外传来骚动，被凯瑟琳尖叫“谋杀，警察”的声音惊醒。基蒂打开前门，正好看到凯瑟琳赤身裸体地冲进来，只穿了一双靴子。基蒂透过门缝看到一个裸体男人的轮廓，随后猛地关上自己的门，并拿了一个沉重的花瓶防身。那名男子用一种异常冷静的声音喊道：“给我点光。小姐，给我一根火柴。”
Kitty opened the door and threw the man a box of matches. He collected them off the floor, then struck one to observe his surroundings. Kitty could make out his pointed chin, but very little else. Have you seen my boots? he then asked. Kitty and Catherine watched nervously as the man stumbled about in the dark, collecting his clothes. When his match burnt out, he lit another. Once he had managed to dress himself, he moved towards Kitty's apartment door. She raised her vase defensively while Catherine gripped her tightly from behind.
基蒂打开门，扔给那人一盒火柴。他从地板上捡起火柴，划亮一根观察周围环境。基蒂能看出他尖尖的下巴，但其他什么也看不清。“你看到我的靴子了吗？”他随后问道。基蒂和凯瑟琳紧张地看着那人在黑暗中跌跌撞撞地收集衣服。当火柴烧完时，他又划亮了一根。一旦他设法穿好衣服，他就朝基蒂的公寓门走去。她举起花瓶防卫，而凯瑟琳从后面紧紧抓住她。
Catherine was well aware of who she had crossed paths with. The man she had brought home had been the topic of conversation amongst those who occupied London streets at night. His horrific acts had reignited memories of an infamous unidentified killer that prowled the city 50 years prior. Jack the Ripper slashed and mutilated sex workers in rage-fueled attacks in London's East End between 1888 and 1891. While some theorised that he might still be alive and was continuing his spree, others were convinced the current killer was merely a copycat. They referred to him as the blackout Ripper.
凯瑟琳很清楚她遇到了谁。她带回家的那个男人一直是伦敦夜间街头人们谈论的话题。他可怕的行为重新点燃了人们对50年前潜伏在城市里的臭名昭著的未识别杀手的记忆。开膛手杰克在1888年至1891年间在伦敦东区愤怒地砍杀和肢解性工作者。虽然一些人推测他可能还活着并继续作案，但另一些人确信现在的凶手只是一个模仿者。他们称他为“灯火管制开膛手”。
You're a murderer, Catherine Mulcahy yelled, as the blackout Ripper approached. Without saying a word, he reached into his pockets and pulled out a wad of cash. He counted out eight pounds in one pound notes and threw them towards Catherine, saying, I'm sorry, I think I had too much to drink. He then walked down the hallway, clambered down the stairs, and headed out into the dark street. It was then that the blackout Ripper crossed paths with Doris Duannet. Several years earlier, Henry Duannet had been aimlessly shopping on Oxford Street when he spotted a woman named Doris waiting at a bus stop. He had noticed her in the West End
“你是杀人犯，”当灯火管制开膛手走近时，凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希尖叫道。他一言不发，伸手进兜掏出一叠现金。他数出八英镑的一英镑纸币扔向凯瑟琳，说道：“对不起，我想我喝多了。”然后他沿着走廊走去，爬下楼梯，走向黑暗的街道。就在那时，灯火管制开膛手与多丽丝·杜安内特擦肩而过。几年前，亨利·杜安内特在牛津街漫无目的地购物时，看到一个名叫多丽丝的女人在公交车站等车。他之前在西区注意到过她，
before but never felt it was appropriate to introduce himself. This was his chance. What followed was a whirlwind romance that led to their marriage two months later. At the outset of the war, like many others, Henry and Doris found themselves in a financially precarious situation. Henry took a job as a staff manager of a hotel on Regent Street. At 7pm on Friday, February 13, he arrived home after spending nearly 24 hours at the hotel. To his surprise, the milk was still sitting on the doorstep from that morning's delivery. Henry opened the front door and called out to Doris. There was no response. It was pitch black and he struggled to find the light switch. Once he did,
但从未觉得主动搭讪合适。这是他的机会。随后是一场旋风般的恋情，两个月后他们结婚了。战争开始时，像许多其他人一样，亨利和多丽丝发现自己处于经济拮据的境地。亨利在摄政街的一家酒店担任员工经理。2月13日星期五晚上7点，他在酒店待了近24小时后回到家。令他惊讶的是，牛奶还放在门口，是当天早上送来的。亨利打开前门呼唤多丽丝。没有回应。里面漆黑一片，他费力地寻找电灯开关。一旦找到，
his eyes were drawn to the remains of last night's meal still sitting on the kitchen table. Henry knew immediately that something was wrong. Doris was extremely tidy and she wouldn't leave food out overnight. Henry walked down the hallway towards their bedroom. He could see that a light was on inside but the door was shut and there was no response when he called out. When Henry tried to open the door, he realized that it had been locked from the inside. Henry rummaged through the apartment looking for something he could use to Jimmy open the door. Unable to find anything and with a growing sense of worry, Henry summoned the police. An officer soon arrived and circled the exterior of the building looking for a window.
他的目光被厨房桌子上昨晚剩下的饭菜吸引了。亨利立刻意识到出了问题。多丽丝非常爱整洁，她不会把食物留在外面过夜。亨利沿着走廊走向他们的卧室。他能看到里面亮着灯，但门关着，他呼唤时没有回应。当亨利试图开门时，他意识到门从里面锁上了。亨利在公寓里翻找可以用来撬开门的东西。找不到任何工具，随着担忧加剧，亨利报了警。一名警察很快赶到，绕着大楼外围寻找窗户。
The one leading into Henry and Doris's bedroom was covered by shutters and also locked from the inside. With no other option, the officer went inside and gave the couple's bedroom door a big hard kick. The door dislodged from its hinges, granting the officer access to the room. His attention was immediately drawn to the bed. Although it appeared to be made, something was clearly underneath the blankets. The officer pulled the cover's back, exposing Doris's and its body. She was naked, aside from a black nightgown that was left open. A silk stocking was wrapped tightly around the 32-year-old's neck.
通往亨利和多丽丝卧室的那扇窗户被百叶窗遮住，也从里面锁上了。别无选择，警察走进屋内，用力猛踢卧室门。门从铰链上脱落，让警察进入了房间。他的注意力立刻被床吸引。虽然床看起来铺好了，但毯子下面显然有什么东西。警察掀开被子，露出了多丽丝的尸体。她赤身裸体，只留下一件敞开的黑色睡衣。一条丝袜紧紧缠绕在这位32岁女性的脖子上。
Flash had been carved out from under her left breast, multiple deep incisions had been made across her body and her genitals had been viciously mutilated. The officer exited the bedroom and told Henry, I must advise you not to go in that room. Detectives who were still in the midst of investigating the murders of Evelyn Hamilton and Evelyn Oatley were summoned to the Juana residence. The blackout ripper had struck again. Henry was aware that Doris had been a sex worker before the two met and he conceded that she must have returned to the profession while he worked nights at the hotel. Still, her murder was a complete mystery to the devastated Henry, who later told reporters,
她左乳房下的肉被挖掉，身上有多处深切口，生殖器遭到残忍肢解。警察走出卧室告诉亨利：“我必须建议你不要进那个房间。”正在调查伊芙琳·汉密尔顿和伊芙琳·奥特利谋杀案的侦探们被传唤到杜安内特住所。灯火管制开膛手再次作案。亨利知道多丽丝在两人相识前曾是性工作者，他承认她一定是在他晚上在酒店工作时重操旧业了。尽管如此，她的谋杀案对悲痛欲绝的亨利来说仍然是一个谜，他后来告诉记者：
we lived for each other. I wish myself dead because we were so fond of each other. As detectives were documenting the crime scene, a police dispatcher pulled up on a motorbike outside. He walked into Doris's room with a letter in hand. Inside was a brief message to detectives. Another body had been found. Earlier that day, 15-year-old Barbara Lowe took the train into London. Barbara attended a boarding school in the resort town of South Andon Sea, but she ventured into London on the third Friday of every month to spend the weekend with her mother Margaret. The pair valued their catch-ups, which were often spent shopping,
“我们为彼此而活。我希望自己死掉，因为我们是如此深爱对方。”当侦探们正在记录犯罪现场时，一名警察调度员骑着摩托车停在外面。他拿着一封信走进多丽丝的房间。里面是给侦探的一条简短信息。又发现了一具尸体。当天早些时候，15岁的芭芭拉·洛乘火车来到伦敦。芭芭拉在度假小镇南安登海的一所寄宿学校上学，但她每个月的第三个星期五都会冒险去伦敦，与母亲玛格丽特共度周末。两人很珍惜她们的相聚，通常是购物、
walking through the city's famed gardens or seeing a film at the cinema. On the afternoon of February 13, 1942, Barbara arrived at her mother's apartment on Gosfield Street in West London. Bags in hand, Barbara excitedly knocked on the front door. There was no response. After trying a few more times, Barbara walked down the road to visit her mother's friend. The friend hadn't seen Margaret for a few days and didn't know where she could be. Barbara spent the next hour wandering the streets, thinking her mother must have gone out and that she might run into her. Failing that, she returned to Gosfield
漫步在城市著名的花园中，或者去电影院看电影。1942年2月13日下午，芭芭拉抵达母亲位于伦敦西区戈斯菲尔德街的公寓。芭芭拉提着包，兴奋地敲门。没有回应。又试了几次后，芭芭拉沿着路去拜访母亲的朋友。那位朋友已经几天没见到玛格丽特了，不知道她会在哪里。芭芭拉花了一个小时在街上徘徊，以为母亲一定是出去了，她可能会碰到她。没能找到，她回到戈斯菲尔德
Street and stood at her mother's door once again, banging loudly. Suddenly, a neighbour's door swung open and he asked Barbara to step inside. Two police officers were waiting within, holding a package that had been left ignored on Margaret's doorstep for several days. Margaret's neighbours had summoned the police after becoming worried. They always kept an eye out for Margaret as they were aware she took on sex work to help pay for her daughter's tuition. As a result, Margaret had met some rough and violent men. Two days earlier in the early hours of February 11, a neighbour had heard a man wearing heavy boots come and go from Margaret's apartment,
街，再次站在母亲门前，用力敲门。突然，邻居的门打开了，他请芭芭拉进去。两名警察在里面等着，手里拿着一个包裹，那个包裹已经在玛格丽特家门口被忽视了好几天。玛格丽特的邻居在感到担忧后报了警。他们一直留意着玛格丽特，因为他们知道她从事性工作来帮助支付女儿的学费。因此，玛格丽特遇到过一些粗鲁暴力的男人。两天前，即2月11日凌晨，一位邻居听到一个穿着厚重靴子的男人进出玛格丽特的公寓，
but they hadn't seen her since. The officers gained access to Margaret's apartment using a set of spare keys. They moved through the darkened sitting room and into the cramped kitchen. At the back was a bedroom with a locked door. Unable to locate a key, one of the officers kicked the door down. The room inside was pitch black. The officer felt along the wall until he came upon a light switch and clicked it on. The burst of light exposed the bed on the right side of the room. Margaret Lowe lay in it, face up with blankets pulled up to her chin. The officer pulled the covers back slightly, revealing a stocking tied tightly around her neck.
但从那以后他们就没见过她。警察用一套备用钥匙进入了玛格丽特的公寓。他们穿过昏暗的客厅，进入狭窄的厨房。后面是一间锁着门的卧室。找不到钥匙，其中一名警察把门踢开了。里面的房间漆黑一片。警察沿着墙摸索，直到找到电灯开关并按了下去。灯光照亮了房间右侧的床。玛格丽特·洛躺在床上，脸朝上，毯子拉到下巴。警察轻轻掀开被子，露出一条紧紧系在她脖子上的丝袜。
Margaret Lowe bore the brunt of a vicious attack. Several incisions had been made around her groin, with one five-inch-long cut partially exposing her internal organs. Lying near Margaret's legs was a large bread knife, two dinner knives, a paring knife, and a metal fire poker, all of which were used in the attack. A wax candle was found inside her, sourced from a glass candle holder on a nearby mantelpiece. The blackout ripper had now claimed four victims within a two-mile radius in just five days. With each new attack surpassing the previous in severity, police knew that at this pace, he could strike again at any moment.
玛格丽特·洛遭受了残酷的袭击。她的腹股沟周围有几处切口，其中一道五英寸长的伤口部分露出了她的内脏。玛格丽特腿边放着一把大面包刀、两把餐刀、一把削皮刀和一根金属火钳，所有这些都被用于袭击。在附近壁炉架上的玻璃烛台中发现了一根蜡烛，被插入了她体内。灯火管制开膛手在短短五天内就在两英里范围内夺走了四名受害者的生命。随着每一次新的袭击在严重程度上都超过前一次，警方知道照此速度，他随时可能再次作案。
Later that evening, 30-year-old Margaret Haywood, who was known to friends as Mary, sat alone in a crowded bar in Piccadilly Circus, a short walk from the West End. She was waiting for a date. Minutes ticked by, and Mary soon reached the conclusion that she had been stood up. As 8.30 approached, a well-dressed and handsome young man walked over and took a seat behind her. In a refined British accent, he asked Mary if she would like a drink. Mary said she was waiting for someone, but this didn't dissuade the man. He carried over two glasses of whiskey, handing one to Mary and downing his own with a single swig. He then stared at Mary, enough to make her uncomfortable.
那天晚上晚些时候，30岁的玛格丽特·海伍德（朋友们称她为玛丽）独自坐在皮卡迪利广场一家拥挤的酒吧里，距离西区仅几步之遥。她在等约会对象。时间一分一秒过去，玛丽很快得出结论，她被放鸽子了。临近8点30分，一名衣着考究、英俊的年轻男子走过来，坐在她身后。他用优雅的英式口音问玛丽是否想喝一杯。玛丽说她在等人，但这并没有劝退那名男子。他拿来两杯威士忌，递给玛丽一杯，自己一口气喝干了另一杯。然后他盯着玛丽看，足以让她感到不舒服。
She didn't care for his overconfidence or charisma, but he persisted. Smiling, he asked to take her to dinner, adding, I have to be back at my unit by 10.30. Mary reluctantly agreed, a decision she regretted the longer she spent in the man's company. At one stage, he took a large wad of notes from his wallet and counted 30 pounds in front of her. Understanding that he was trying to proposition her, Mary clarified that she wasn't a sex worker and went to leave. The man persisted, calling her a nice girl, and saying he fancied her. Mary remained firm, but ultimately agreed to give him her phone number.
她不喜欢他的过度自信或魅力，但他坚持不懈。他微笑着请求带她去吃晚饭，并补充说：“我必须在10点30分前回到我的部队。”玛丽勉强同意了，这个决定让她在与该男子相处的过程中越发后悔。有一次，他从钱包里拿出一大叠钞票，在她面前数了30英镑。明白他是在试图向她搭讪，玛丽澄清说她不是性工作者，并准备离开。那名男子坚持不懈，称她是个好女孩，说他看上她了。玛丽态度坚定，但最终同意给他电话号码。
She wrote it down on a piece of paper that the man slipped into his coat pocket. Mary moved towards the door and the man followed her out, insisting they spent the night together. While Mary found him handsome, she didn't even know his name. She continued to refuse his advances until he seemingly accepted the rejection and said he'd escort her back to Piccadilly Circus. They walked along in silence when all of a sudden the man asked, Do you know that I knocked a girl out once? He said the girl's father had interfered in their relationship, which prompted him to lash out.
她把它写在一张纸条上，那名男子把它塞进了大衣口袋。玛丽朝门口走去，那名男子跟着她出来，坚持要他们一起过夜。虽然玛丽觉得他很英俊，但她甚至不知道他的名字。她继续拒绝他的追求，直到他似乎接受了拒绝，并说他会护送她回皮卡迪利广场。他们沉默地走着，突然那名男子问：“你知道我曾经打晕过一个女孩吗？”他说那个女孩的父亲干涉了他们的关系，这促使他大打出手。
It was a strange remark, but the man didn't elaborate. He just continued onwards. Struggling to see through the dark, Mary stumbled on some uneven pavement and took a small flashlight from her back. She had just turned it on when the man yanked it from her hands and switched it off, admonishing her for shining light in the street. It was then that Mary realized they were heading in the wrong direction. Mary pointed this out, but the man brushed off her concerns. He wanted to kiss her and asked Mary if she knew of any bomb shelters nearby. Unsure what to do, Mary walked with him a little longer until he eventually pulled her into an arched doorway. He tried to undress her, but Mary fought back and attempted to run.
这是一个奇怪的言论，但那名男子没有详细说明。他只是继续向前走。在黑暗中难以看清，玛丽在不平坦的人行道上绊了一下，从包里拿出一支小手电筒。她刚打开，那名男子就从她手中夺过并关掉，责备她在街上开灯。就在那时，玛丽意识到他们走错了方向。玛丽指出了这一点，但那名男子不以为意。他想吻她，并问玛丽是否知道附近有什么防空洞。不确定该怎么办，玛丽又和他走了一会儿，直到他最终把她拉进一个拱形门口。他试图脱掉她的衣服，但玛丽反抗并试图逃跑。
The man grabbed her arm, pulled her back, and blocked the entrance to the doorway so she couldn't escape. He then wrapped his hands around Mary's neck. Seemingly in a trance and with little emotion, he pressed his thumbs into Mary's windpipe as she struggled against him. The last thing she heard was the sound of his voice whispering over and over. It was approaching 10 p.m. when 18-year-old John Shine walked through St James's market towards Regent Street. He was passing a shallow side alley when he noticed a flashlight flickering on and off from under a doorway. Driven by curiosity, John headed towards the light when he overheard the sound of a scuffle. Following the noise, John stopped.
那名男子抓住她的胳膊，把她拉回来，挡住了门口，让她无法逃脱。然后他用双手掐住玛丽的脖子。他似乎处于恍惚状态，几乎没有情绪，将拇指按在玛丽的气管上，而她在反抗。她听到的最后一件事是他低声耳语的声音，一遍又一遍。晚上快10点时，18岁的约翰·沙恩穿过圣詹姆斯市场走向摄政街。他经过一条浅浅的小巷时，注意到门口下方有一支手电筒忽明忽暗。出于好奇，约翰朝光亮处走去，这时他听到了打斗声。循着声音，约翰停下了脚步。
He could see a young woman lying in the doorway. A man stood over her, holding the flashlight that had caught John's attention earlier. As soon as the man noticed John's presence, he dropped the flashlight and took off into the darkened surroundings. John rushed towards the woman. It was Mary Haywood. She lay unmoving with her head against the door and legs pointing to the street. Her dress had been torn open and pulled up, exposing her thighs. Her face was dirty and smeared with blood. John knelt down beside Mary when all of a sudden she began to moan in pain. He tried to help Mary to her feet, but her legs were weak and she was disorientated. A police officer who happened to be passing by noticed them and made his way over to help.
他看到一个年轻女子躺在门口。一个男人站在她上方，手里拿着之前引起约翰注意的手电筒。那人一察觉到约翰的存在，就扔掉手电筒，逃进了黑暗中。约翰冲向那个女人。是玛丽·海伍德。她一动不动地躺着，头靠在门上，双腿指向街道。她的裙子被撕开并向上拉起，露出了大腿。她的脸很脏，沾满了血迹。约翰在玛丽身边跪下，突然她开始痛苦地呻吟。他试图扶玛丽站起来，但她的双腿无力，神志不清。一名恰好路过的警察注意到了他们，走过来帮忙。
Mary began to cry. What has he done? She pointed at her bag which was lying on the ground, its contents scattered about. Just as she went to collect her things, John noticed a small pack lying in the doorway. It was a haversack which was a type of bag typically carried by military personnel. Inside was a gas mask. While the constant fear of being bombed loomed over Londoners, the average person was far more worried about a chemical gas attack. Potentially fatal mustard gas had been deployed during World War I and there was a genuine fear it might be used against civilians again.
玛丽开始哭泣。他做了什么？她指着躺在地上的包，里面的东西散落一地。就在她去捡东西时，约翰注意到门口放着一个小包。那是一个帆布背包，通常是军事人员携带的那种。里面有一个防毒面具。虽然伦敦人一直笼罩在被轰炸的恐惧中，但普通人更担心的是化学毒气袭击。第一次世界大战期间曾使用过可能致命的芥子气，人们确实担心它会再次被用于平民。
As a precautionary measure, the London County Council suggested that civilians carry a gas mask with them at all times. John Shine picked the gas mask up off the ground and asked Mary if it was hers. She said no. Mary Haywood had survived an encounter with the Blackout Ripper. After taking her statement, the attending officer collected the haversack and the gas mask that the killer had left behind. Printed on the bag's inside flap was a Royal Air Force number. 525987 Fight our pilot. The words convey something of the spirit that lies in our squadrons.
作为预防措施，伦敦郡议会建议平民随身携带防毒面具。约翰·沙恩从地上捡起防毒面具，问玛丽是不是她的。她说不是。玛丽·海伍德在与“灯火管制开膛手”的遭遇中幸存了下来。在记录了她的陈述后，在场的警官收走了凶手留下的帆布背包和防毒面具。包的内盖上印着一个英国皇家空军的编号。525987。战斗我们的飞行员。这些话传达了我们中队所蕴含的精神。
Something young and vigorous, decisive, wanting action at once and finding its expression in the struggle going on daily over our southeastern shores. But you have not yet been led into the mind of the men who do the flying, nor shown their feelings when in the air and going into a fight. The long periods of waiting are a test of temperament. Some pilots occupy themselves actively, others pass the time in sleep. Corporal Charles Johnson of the Royal Air Force was stationed at the Air Crew Receiving Centre at St James Close in Regents Park.
一种年轻、充满活力、果断、渴望立即行动的精神，并在我们东南部海岸每天进行的斗争中得到了体现。但你还没有被带入飞行员的内心世界，也没有看到他们在空中进入战斗时的感受。漫长的等待是对性情的考验。一些飞行员积极地忙碌着，另一些则在睡眠中打发时间。英国皇家空军的查尔斯·约翰逊下士驻扎在摄政公园圣詹姆斯广场的空勤人员接待中心。
At 10.30 that Friday night, the phone rang. On the other end was a police officer. I need you to search records and trace the number of an airman, Corporal Johnson was told. He grabbed a pen. 525987 The number was allotted to leading aircraftman 28-year-old Gordon Cummins. Cummins had arrived at the centre on February 2 to begin training as a fighter pilot. A week later, Evelyn Hamilton was murdered in a bomb shelter less than half a mile away. Corporal Johnson went to inform Cummins that the police wished to speak to him, but he was nowhere to be found. A 10.30pm curfew was in place for cadets,
那个周五晚上10点30分，电话响了。电话那头是一名警察。约翰逊下士被告知：“我需要你搜索记录并追踪一名飞行员的编号。”他抓起一支笔。525987。这个编号分配给了28岁的首席飞行员戈登·卡明斯。卡明斯于2月2日抵达中心开始接受战斗机飞行员训练。一周后，伊芙琳·汉密尔顿在不到半英里外的一个防空洞中被谋杀。约翰逊下士去通知卡明斯警察想找他谈话，但他却不见踪影。学员们有晚上10点30分的宵禁，
but it wasn't until 4.30am that Cummins was spotted trying to sneak into his living quarters. He apologised, explaining that he'd been drinking heavily and had trouble making it back in time. It wasn't particularly unusual for cadets to break curfew, as they often ventured into the city at night to let off steam and overindulge. When Cummins was informed that his gas mask had been found at the scene of a crime, he seemed confused. He had his haversack with him with his gas mask inside. However, the number inside the bag confirmed it wasn't his. Cummins then realised what must have happened. He'd been drinking at a pub with other cadets
但直到凌晨4点30分，卡明斯才被发现试图溜回宿舍。他道歉说，他喝多了，没能及时赶回来。学员违反宵禁并不罕见，因为他们经常在晚上冒险进入城市放松和过度放纵。当卡明斯被告知他的防毒面具在犯罪现场被发现时，他显得很困惑。他随身带着帆布背包，里面装着防毒面具。然而，包里的编号证实那不是他的。卡明斯随后意识到发生了什么。他和其他学员在一家酒吧喝酒，
and had placed his haversack by his feet alongside the others. Someone must have taken his by mistake. The heavily intoxicated Cummins couldn't remember exactly who had joined him that night, and of those he could remember, he didn't know their names. But he was confident he'd be able to recognise them if he saw them again. Cummins was taken to the West End Central Police Station, where he was directly questioned about Mary Haywood. The two had been drinking at the same Piccadilly Circus pub prior to Mary's attack. Cummins spoke of having a hazy recollection of walking around the streets with a woman,
并把他的帆布背包放在脚边，和其他人的放在一起。一定是有人拿错了他的。醉醺醺的卡明斯记不清那天晚上到底有谁和他在一起，而在他能记住的人中，他也不知道他们的名字。但他确信如果再见到他们，他能认出他们。卡明斯被带到西区中央警察局，在那里他被直接询问关于玛丽·海伍德的事。两人在玛丽遇袭前曾在同一个皮卡迪利广场的酒吧喝酒。卡明斯说他模糊地记得和一个女人在街上走，
but was too drunk to remember what happened after that. He denied attacking Mary, saying, I remembered I should be back at my depot. I caught a cab and went to Regents Park. Cummins agreed to provide a written statement, during which detectives noticed that he wrote with his left hand. There were also fresh abrasions across his knuckles, which Cummins claimed had occurred when he was working on an aeroplane motor. When asked to view a police line-up that featured Cummins, Mary Haywood unhesitantly identified him as the man who had assaulted her. Cummins maintained his innocence, stating that Mary must have confused him with another airman
但喝得太醉，记不起之后发生了什么。他否认袭击了玛丽，说：“我记得我应该回到我的驻地。我叫了一辆出租车去了摄政公园。”卡明斯同意提供一份书面陈述，在此期间侦探们注意到他用左手写字。他的指关节上也有新鲜的擦伤，卡明斯声称这是他在修理飞机发动机时弄伤的。当被要求观看包含卡明斯的警察列队辨认时，玛丽·海伍德毫不犹豫地指认他就是袭击她的人。卡明斯坚称自己无罪，称玛丽一定把他和另一名飞行员搞混了，
who was attempting to frame him. Detectives were unconvinced by his story and placed him under arrest for assault. Inside Cummins' pockets, police found an array of miscellaneous and seemingly trivial items, including a plastic comb with some teeth missing, a fountain tip pen engraved with the initials DJ, and a wristwatch with a broken band that had been repaired with tape. He also had a strip of paper with a number on it. It was Mary Haywood's phone number scrawled in her handwriting. She had told police that she'd given it to her assailant prior to the attack. The question remained, was Gordon Cummins the blackout ripper? Evidence had pointed to the four-time killer being in some way connected to the Royal Air Force. The man who had attempted
那个人试图陷害他。侦探们对他的说法并不信服，以袭击罪将他逮捕。在卡明斯的口袋里，警察发现了一系列杂乱且看似琐碎的物品，包括一把缺齿的塑料梳子、一支刻有DJ首字母的钢笔，以及一块表带断裂并用胶带修复的手表。他还有一张纸条，上面写着一个数字。那是玛丽·海伍德的电话号码，用她的笔迹潦草地写着。她告诉警察，她在袭击前把它给了袭击者。问题仍然是，戈登·卡明斯是“灯火管制开膛手”吗？证据表明这名四次杀人犯与英国皇家空军有某种联系。那个试图
to strangle Catherine Mulcahy in her apartment had left behind an item of clothing as he scrambled around in the dark trying to get dressed before fleeing. It was a belt which was part of the Royal Air Force uniform. This aligned with the recollections of the other women who had interacted with the ripper. They all said he claimed to be an airman. Positioned at the entry hall of the St. James Close Aircrew Receiving Center was a logbook. Cadets were required to record the time they left and returned each day with an orderly stationed at the logbook to ensure that everyone complied. A detective flipped through the book to the dates and time periods that Evelyn Hamilton, Evelyn Oatley, Doris Duannet, and Margaret Low
在公寓里勒死凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希的男人在黑暗中手忙脚乱地穿衣服准备逃跑时留下了一件衣物。那是一条属于英国皇家空军制服的腰带。这与曾与开膛手接触过的其他女性的回忆相吻合。她们都说他自称是飞行员。在圣詹姆斯广场空勤人员接待中心的大厅入口处放着一本日志。学员们每天必须记录离开和返回的时间，并由一名值班人员守在日志旁以确保每个人都遵守规定。一名侦探翻阅了日志，查看伊芙琳·汉密尔顿、伊芙琳·奥特利、多丽丝·杜安内特和玛格丽特·洛
were killed. To his surprise, Gordon Cummins' name was signed in on each occasion, meaning he was at the centre when each woman was targeted. Yet something stood out. While some of the logbook entries were penned in ink, others had been scrawled in pencil. All of Cummins' entries coinciding with the time of the murders were in pencil, meaning they could have easily been altered. In some cases, they were written in a different pencil to all the others on the page. An entire page from that week was also missing, with the entries from another date copied into its place. The detective wrote in his report, The booking in book at St. James' Close is far from being a true record of men being off duty.
遇害的日期和时间段。令他惊讶的是，戈登·卡明斯的签名出现在每一次记录中，这意味着他在每个受害者遇害时都在中心。然而，有些事情很突出。虽然日志中的一些条目是用墨水写的，但另一些是用铅笔潦草写成的。卡明斯所有与谋杀时间吻合的条目都是用铅笔写的，这意味着它们很容易被篡改。在某些情况下，它们使用的铅笔与页面上的其他条目不同。那一周的整整一页也不见了，取而代之的是从另一个日期复制过来的条目。侦探在报告中写道：“圣詹姆斯广场的登记簿远非人员离岗的真实记录。”
According to the cadets who bunked with Cummins, he often stayed out past Curfew and snuck back in before dawn. When he went out with others, Cummins would sometimes go off on his own. It was no secret that he was out seeking sex workers. Cummins, with his unruly, wavy blonde hair, trimmed mustache, narrow facial features, and wide smile, was considered an attractive man who often bragged about his conquests. He had earned the reputation amongst his fellow cadets as being a lady's man and a party animal. Women were often charmed by his looks, intellect, and refined British accent as it reflected nobility and wealth. A search of the trashcans outside of the aircrew receiving centre's entrance resulted in an unusual
据与卡明斯同住的学员说，他经常在宵禁后外出，并在黎明前溜回来。当他和别人一起出去时，卡明斯有时会独自行动。他外出寻找性工作者并不是什么秘密。卡明斯有着凌乱的波浪状金发、修剪整齐的胡须、狭窄的面部特征和灿烂的笑容，被认为是一个有吸引力的男人，经常吹嘘自己的征服经历。他在学员中赢得了“花花公子”和“派对狂”的名声。女性经常被他的外表、智慧和精致的英国口音所吸引，因为这反映了高贵和财富。对空勤人员接待中心入口外的垃圾桶进行搜查，结果发现了一个不同寻常的
find, the soles of two shoes with a distinctive tread pattern. Back at the police station, Gordon Cummins was asked to show detectives the soles of his shoes. Surprised, he lifted his feet for the detective to see. The tops of his soles had been replaced with a new tread. Although no discernible boot prints had been uncovered at any of the crime scenes, detectives theorised that Cummins had changed the soles out of fear that their unusual pattern might be traced back to him. When asked to explain why he had recently changed the soles of his shoes, Cummins just shrugged his shoulders.
发现：两只鞋底，带有独特的胎面花纹。回到警察局，戈登·卡明斯被要求向侦探展示他的鞋底。他惊讶地抬起脚让侦探看。他的鞋底顶部已经换成了新的胎面。虽然在任何犯罪现场都没有发现明显的靴子印，但侦探们推测卡明斯换掉鞋底是因为担心它们独特的图案可能会追溯到他身上。当被问及为什么要换鞋底时，卡明斯只是耸了耸肩。
The aircrew receiving centre was searched extensively, revealing a significant item in the very back of a cupboard in the shared kitchenette. It was a white metal cigarette case engraved with the initials LW. Inside was a photograph of a woman. It didn't resemble any of the victims, but when shown to their loved ones, Evelyn Oatley's former husband identified the case as belonging to his actress wife, who used the stage name Lita Ward. The photograph inside was of her mother. Detective's showed the items found in Gordon Cummins' pockets to the victim's families. Doris Duannet's husband, Henry, immediately recognised the comb, fountain pen and wristwatch
空勤人员接待中心经过了彻底搜查，在共用小厨房的一个橱柜最深处发现了一件重要物品。那是一个白色的金属烟盒，刻有LW的首字母。里面有一张女人的照片。它看起来不像任何受害者，但当展示给她们的亲人看时，伊芙琳·奥特利的前夫认出这个烟盒属于他那艺名为丽塔·沃德的演员妻子。里面的照片是她母亲的。侦探们向受害者家属展示了在戈登·卡明斯口袋里发现的物品。多丽丝·杜安内特的丈夫亨利立即认出了那把梳子、钢笔和手表
as having belonged to Doris. A connection was also established to Evelyn Hamilton via a green lead pencil that was found in a dustbin in Cummins living quarters. She had borrowed it from a friend shortly before her murder. The night after Evelyn was killed, Cummins was seen flashing a large amount of money. Given that around 80 pounds was stolen from Evelyn's purse, this had likely been her money. Two one-pound notes that the blackout ripper had tossed at Catherine Mulcahy featured serial numbers that were traced back to cash that was paid to Gordon Cummins earlier that day. Traces of blood were found on Cummins' clothing,
是属于多丽丝的。通过在卡明斯宿舍的垃圾桶里发现的一支绿色铅笔，也建立了与伊芙琳·汉密尔顿的联系。她在谋杀前不久从朋友那里借了这支笔。伊芙琳遇害后的第二天晚上，有人看到卡明斯炫耀大量的钱。考虑到伊芙琳的钱包里被偷了大约80英镑，这很可能是她的钱。灯火管制开膛手扔给凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希的两张一英镑纸币上的序列号，被追溯到当天早些时候支付给戈登·卡明斯的现金。在卡明斯的衣服上发现了血迹，
but restraints in scientific testing meant it couldn't be compared to the blood of the victims. Yet, there was one test that could provide investigators with a smoking gun. Detective Chief Superintendent Frederick Ceryl had been working the blackout ripper case since the murder of Evelyn Hamilton. Ceryl was the head of Scotland Yards Fingerprint Division and regarded the country's leading fingerprint expert. He had managed to lift several key fingerprints from two of the ripper's crime scenes. Two were uncovered in Evelyn Oatley's apartment. One was on the can opener that was used to mutilate her and the other on a piece of glass in her purse. He'd also found foreign fingerprints on a candle holder in Margaret
但科学测试的局限性意味着它无法与受害者的血液进行比对。然而，有一项测试可以为调查人员提供确凿证据。侦探总警司弗雷德里克·塞里尔自伊芙琳·汉密尔顿被谋杀以来一直负责灯火管制开膛手案。塞里尔是苏格兰场指纹部门的负责人，被认为是全国领先的指纹专家。他成功地从开膛手的两个犯罪现场提取了几个关键指纹。在伊芙琳·奥特利的公寓里发现了两个。一个在用于肢解她的开罐器上，另一个在她钱包里的一块玻璃片上。他还发现玛格丽特
Lowe's bedroom. It had held the candle that was later found inside her body. Gordon Cummins' fingerprints were taken upon his arrest and Detective Ceryl cross-checked them against those from the crime scenes. They were a match. Furthermore, traces of mortar on Cummins' haversack matched that found in the bomb shelter where Evelyn Hamilton was murdered. Gordon Cummins was ultimately charged with the murders of Evelyn Hamilton, Evelyn Oatley, Doris Duannet, Margaret Lowe, and the attempted murders of Catherine Mulcahy and Mary Haywood. He was examined by a medical officer to determine if he was suffering from any mental illness that might have influenced his violent behaviour. The doctor concluded,
洛卧室的烛台上留有外人的指纹。那个烛台后来被发现插在她的体内。戈登·卡明斯在被捕时被采集了指纹，塞里尔侦探将它们与犯罪现场的指纹进行了交叉比对。它们吻合了。此外，卡明斯帆布背包上的砂浆痕迹与伊芙琳·汉密尔顿遇害的防空洞中发现的痕迹相符。戈登·卡明斯最终被控谋杀伊芙琳·汉密尔顿、伊芙琳·奥特利、多丽丝·杜安内特、玛格丽特·洛，并被控企图谋杀凯瑟琳·穆尔卡希和玛丽·海伍德。他接受了医官的检查，以确定他是否患有任何可能影响其暴力行为的精神疾病。医生得出结论，
the character and sights of the wounds inflicted on the victims points to a sadistic basis for the murders. But throughout the period he has been in my care, the accused has been normal in conduct and rational in conversation. At no time has he exhibited any evidence of mental disease. This assessment aligned with those who knew Cummins. While some found him vain and pompous, he had never shown a dark side or a disdain for women. His father described him as a normal person without any cruelty in his nature. Superior officers praised his military discipline and physical abilities which surpassed his fellow cadets. Sex workers he'd been with didn't describe him as aggressive. Cummins also had a wife who steadfastly defended him.
“受害者伤口的特征和景象表明谋杀具有施虐倾向。但在我照顾他的整个期间，被告的行为正常，谈话理性。他从未表现出任何精神疾病的迹象。”这一评估与认识卡明斯的人的看法一致。虽然有些人觉得他虚荣且自负，但他从未表现出阴暗面或对女性的蔑视。他的父亲形容他是一个正常人，天性中没有残忍。上级军官称赞他的军事纪律和身体素质超过了其他学员。与他在一起的性工作者并没有形容他具有攻击性。卡明斯还有一位坚定地为他辩护的妻子。
Yet, some noted that he had a gift for storytelling that would convince listeners that whatever he was saying was the truth. He was also caught lying about his whereabouts on the night of the murders, claiming he had alibis that were later disproven. English law dictated that if someone was facing multiple criminal counts, they only faced trial for one. Therefore, in April 1942, Cummins was tried for the murder of Evelyn Oatley. The prosecution felt they were more likely to secure a guilty verdict with this charge, as it was the only one in which Cummins' fingerprints were found on an item directly used to assault the victim. Cummins pleaded not guilty and appeared his typical happy and relaxed
然而，有些人注意到他有一种讲故事的天赋，能让听众相信他所说的任何话都是事实。他还被发现对谋杀当晚的行踪撒谎，声称有后来被证明是虚假的不在场证明。英国法律规定，如果某人面临多项刑事指控，他只需接受一项审判。因此，1942年4月，卡明斯因谋杀伊芙琳·奥特利受审。检方认为他们更有可能通过这项指控获得有罪判决，因为这是唯一一项在直接用于袭击受害者的物品上发现卡明斯指纹的指控。卡明斯拒不认罪，表现得一如既往地快乐和放松，
throughout proceedings, even laughing with his lawyers. When he took the stand, Cummins admitted he had been in Evelyn Oatley's company shortly before her murder, but insisted she was alive and well when they parted ways. He had told disinformation to police, but to Cummins dismay, they immediately accused him of being Evelyn's killer. Cummins said one officer remarked, We have a rope around your neck and are going to hang you with it. The officer who Cummins accused of making this threat denided wholeheartedly. The prosecution's case rested primarily on the fingerprint evidence, as it showed Cummins had
在整个诉讼过程中，甚至和他的律师谈笑风生。当他出庭作证时，卡明斯承认他在伊芙琳·奥特利遇害前不久曾与她在一起，但坚称他们分手时她还活着且安然无恙。他曾向警方提供虚假信息，但令卡明斯沮丧的是，他们立即指控他是伊芙琳的凶手。卡明斯说一名警官评论道：“我们已经把绳子套在你的脖子上了，我们要用它吊死你。”卡明斯指控发出这种威胁的警官全盘否认。检方的案件主要基于指纹证据，因为它显示卡明斯曾
handled the sharp can opener used to mutilate Evelyn's genitals. The defense worked to discredit the prints, calling them very faint and imperfect. Renowned fingerprint expert, Detective Chief Superintendent Frederick Cheryl stood by his findings. He was asked, Would you stake your reputation knowing that a man is being tried for his life? Without hesitation, Cheryl responded, Yes. The jury deliberated for only 35 minutes before returning to the courtroom, where Cummins stood before them with fists clenched. The presiding judge summed up that the murder of Evelyn Oatley was a sadistic sexual murder of a ghoulish type. Gordon Cummins was found guilty. When asked if he had anything to say, Cummins started, I am completely innocent, sir.
接触过用于肢解伊芙琳生殖器的锋利开罐器。辩方试图诋毁这些指纹，称它们非常模糊且不完整。著名的指纹专家、侦探总警司弗雷德里克·塞里尔坚持他的发现。有人问他：“在知道一个人正面临死刑审判的情况下，你愿意拿你的名誉做赌注吗？”塞里尔毫不犹豫地回答：“是的。”陪审团仅审议了35分钟就回到了法庭，卡明斯握紧拳头站在他们面前。主审法官总结说，谋杀伊芙琳·奥特利是一起令人毛骨悚然的施虐性性谋杀。戈登·卡明斯被判有罪。当被问及有什么话要说时，卡明斯开始说：“我完全是无辜的，先生。”
The judge then donned a square black cap that historically was only ever worn by English judges when delivering the following sentence, quote, There is only one sentence which the law permits me to pronounce, and that is that you be taken to a place of execution, and that you be there hanged by the neck until you are dead. And may the Lord have mercy on your soul. In the lead up to his execution, Gordon Cummins exhausted all avenues of appeal. His family believed in his innocence and wrote to the Home Secretary claiming it was a miscarriage of justice. A petition supporting Cummins received 10,000 signatures, with his supporters highlighting his lack of violent history and clean criminal record. They questioned how someone so
法官随后戴上了一顶方形黑帽，历史上只有英国法官在宣判以下判决时才会佩戴，引用如下：“法律允许我宣判的只有一种判决，那就是你将被带到行刑地点，并在那里被绞死，直到你死亡。愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。”在执行死刑前，戈登·卡明斯用尽了所有上诉途径。他的家人相信他是无辜的，并写信给内政大臣，声称这是一起司法不公。一份支持卡明斯的请愿书获得了10,000个签名，支持者强调他没有暴力历史且犯罪记录清白。他们质疑一个如此
straight and narrow could abruptly begin killing women in such an immensely violent and personal way. The Home Secretary wrote the same response to all letters. I have considered sympathetically and carefully all the circumstances of the case. I regret I have failed to discover any grounds which justify me in advising his majesty to interfere in the due course of the law. In October 1941, just four months before Evelyn Hamilton was killed, the body of 19 year old Maple Church was found in the wreckage of a building destroyed by overhead bombings in London's Camden Town. Maple had been strangled with her undergarments as well as mutilated. Analysis of the wounds showed the killer was
正直的人怎么会突然开始以如此极其暴力和个人的方式杀害女性。内政大臣对所有信件都写了同样的回复：“我已经同情且仔细地考虑了案件的所有情况。我很遗憾，我没有发现任何理由可以证明我建议国王干预法律的正当程序。”1941年10月，就在伊芙琳·汉密尔顿遇害前四个月，19岁的梅普尔·丘奇的尸体在伦敦卡姆登镇被空中轰炸摧毁的建筑物废墟中被发现。梅普尔被她的内衣勒死并被肢解。对伤口的分析显示凶手
likely left handed. Maple had also been robbed. Four days after Maple's body was discovered, the unconscious body of 49 year old Edith Humphreys was found lying across her bed in her flat just half a mile away. Her skull had been fractured with a penetrating stab wound to her brain and her jaw was broken. There were also signs she had been manually strangled. Edith was still clinging to life and was rushed to hospital but died of her injuries later that day. Reports differ but many say that Edith had been robbed with the jewelry and money missing. With no signs of forced entry, it appeared she had willingly let her killer into her home. A background check showed that Gordon Cummins was in the area when
很可能是左撇子。梅普尔也被抢劫了。在梅普尔的尸体被发现四天后，49岁的伊迪丝·汉弗莱斯昏迷的尸体被发现躺在距离不到半英里远的公寓床上。她的头骨被击碎，大脑有穿透性刺伤，下巴骨折。还有迹象表明她曾被手动勒死。伊迪丝当时还有生命迹象，被紧急送往医院，但当天晚些时候因伤势过重死亡。报告各不相同，但许多人说伊迪丝被抢劫了，珠宝和钱财不见了。没有强行闯入的迹象，看来她是自愿让凶手进入家中的。背景调查显示，戈登·卡明斯在
the murders of Maple Church and Edith Humphreys took place. Despite intensive investigations, both cases remained unsolved. Yet, given their similarities to the blackout ripper's known crimes, many have theorized that Maple and Edith might have been his first victims. To this day, Scotland Yard strongly believes Gordon Cummins was responsible for these crimes. The man himself would never lay claim to any of the murders he was accused of, maintaining his innocence up until June 1942 when he was led to the hangman's noose. He offered no resistance and appeared stoic when the rope was placed around his neck. Gordon Cummins was pronounced dead minutes after 8am to the tune of an air raid siren blasting over
梅普尔·丘奇和伊迪丝·汉弗莱斯谋杀案发生时就在该地区。尽管进行了深入调查，这两起案件仍未破获。然而，考虑到它们与灯火管制开膛手已知罪行的相似之处，许多人推测梅普尔和伊迪丝可能是他的第一批受害者。直到今天，苏格兰场仍坚信戈登·卡明斯应对这些罪行负责。他本人从未承认过他被指控的任何谋杀案，直到1942年6月他被带到绞刑架前，他一直坚称自己无罪。他没有反抗，当绳子套在脖子上时显得很冷静。戈登·卡明斯在上午8点后几分钟被宣布死亡，伴随着在伦敦上空响起的空袭警报声。
London. At that exact time, city dwellers huddled nervously in makeshift shelters, listening for the sound of encroaching German aeroplanes. For Londoners, their fears had returned to the war, now that the blackout ripper was no longer lurking in the night. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那个确切的时间，城市居民紧张地挤在临时避难所里，听着德国飞机逼近的声音。对于伦敦人来说，随着灯火管制开膛手不再潜伏在夜色中，他们的恐惧又回到了战争本身。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。